qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi tu es en
colère comme ça tu étais complètement
folle de lui il ya deux jours il a une
femme voilà il est marié et tu crois que
tu es pas à la hauteur peu importe je
fais pas dans les mecs marié je ne veux
pas briser le foyer d'un homme pour une
aventure c'est pas obligé cette année
moi on était mariée au départ mais pas
heureux mais vous avez brisé deux
mariages un des deux était le mien donc
ça compte pas c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche que je veux dire c'est que les
mecs mariés seraient des plantes parfait
pour toi je crois qu'ils font un homme
qui a quelque chose d'autre pour
l'occuper pas une femme
ok t'es peut-être négative je dois mon à
lyon mais je te laisse méditer sur une
phrase essentielle qui me vient de ma
mère les égoïstes vivent plus longtemps
je dis ça je dis rien alors que son
indice provisoire
c'est